Ron DeSantis
decision to announce his 2024 campaign
on Twitter
with CEO Elon
Musk has unleashed new criticism
of Musk and Twitter.
A new article in The Atlantic goes
as far as declaring, quote,
Twitter is a far right social network.
The author of that article,
Charlie Wall, joins me now.
Charlie.
Time reader, First-Time Caller.
Musk has been sharing
conspiracy theories
on Twitter for months.
He's reinstated
white nationalist accounts
that have been banned.
So why make this declaration now
Well, I think that you can just see
over the last couple of weeks, honestly,
you know,
and despite
what Elon
Musk is doing with his own tweets right
you've seen the platform
as basically a like a safe
haven for people
who've either lost their sinecure
as on
cable news
or people
who've been demonetized on Twitter.
And I'm talking about The Daily Wire,
which got demonetized
a couple of their channels for
anti-trans commentary.
And Tucker Carlson,
who lost his his tenure on Fox News.
Those those people are seeing Twitter
as a safe place for them to go
and perhaps to share revenue.
And Elon Musk seems to be
welcoming them in with open arms.
And yesterday was sort of the the the
the last sort
of making all the subtext text where
he's inviting
Ron DeSantis to come launch
a political campaign there.
So I think, you know,
this isn't about the content that you can
necessarily see.
You could still obviously see
liberal, leftist,
mainstream media content
all sorts of stuff on Twitter.
But when you talk about the actions
and the outcomes of the platform
that you're seeing on the platform,
I think it's it's
you know, it's really
just balls and strikes here.
This is a
right wing social media platform.
That's what it's courting.
So Musk, if he were here right now,
would say, hey, it's
just a free speech platform.
It's just different than it was under
the previous owners.
And we're
just inviting voices
that were unfairly shut out.
Why do you disagree?
Well, I mean, I think that it's actually
a bit of a business strategy here
when you are looking at some of the other
they're called alt
tech alternative
tech platforms
that have catered to conservatives.
And I'm talking about,
you know, true social or parler.
You're seeing that, you know,
their numbers have actually gone down
since Elon Musk has taken over
the platform.
And that's
because there's really,
you know, no real need to build a right
wing Twitter clone,
because Twitter serves that role
so well right now.
And I think, you know,
if you look at Elon Musk's purchase
in general of the platform,
it was an explicitly political act.
Yes.
It's couched
in the language of free speech.
But what he is
essentially saying is there is a lot of,
you know,
there's a Woke Mind
virus out in the world to quote him.
And he wants to counter that by bringing
all of these different voices
in and honestly,
to drown out a lot of the voices
that he doesn't like.
And this is not a,
you know, a town square.
This is a a company that is run by a man
who has a very specific ideology
that he's not afraid to
share with people.
And I think he's making decisions
with the
with the social network
or the platform that are intended
to advance that ideology.
And you see Ron DeSantis
announcing his presidential race
on Twitter spaces, which is an audio
as part as a natural progression of that
I do.
I think that, you know, there are
there are a lot of platforms that,
you know,
he could
that he could go to,
that Ron DeSantis could go to.
He's choosing Twitter
because he sees the owner
as sympathetic to him
as someone who's not going to say
if he came on CNN
and got raked over the coals,
perhaps, or really
pressed on a bunch of issues.
He has a sympathetic audience here.
And I think that he can see to that the
the people
who are sort of left on Twitter
now after there's been a big exodus
and the people who are most sympathetic
are are
these people who share
this ideology, who love that?
You know, DeSantis is has an extremely
online campaign
and loves to own the libs.
I think that, you know,
these things are real reasons why
why DeSantis and his campaign
chose Twitter as a venue.
And I think that it's just more evidence
that,
you know,
this platform is explicitly catering
to and a safe space
for a, you know, a far right ideology.
Charlie Warren's.
Well, thank you so much. Good to see you.
Good to see you, too.